from director Christopher Nolan comes
the obligatory finale to his Dark Knight
trilogy that clearly peaked with the
Joker The Dark Knight Rises the epic
final chapter that are mildly
entertaining when you're watching it but
will ultimately anger and disappoint you
when you really start to think about it
revisit the iconic Bruce Wayne a man who
turned the pain of his parents death
into a superhero but for some reason
mopes around for eight years after his
sort-of girlfriend dies suit up as he
spends the first 45 minutes hobbling
around on canes getting knocked over
easily growing a gross depression beard
and be told that his body is in complete
shambles even though in the entire
trilogy
he's only clocked in maybe a year and a
half as the Batman but chaos will arrive
in the form of Bane a villain who no one
can fully understand this is Custer
studies rather than the truth about to
spend an efference and about this
control captain prompting boatman to
unretire and plop on a magic knee brace
that will instantly curate him so he can
take pain head-on for a few minutes
until he's crippled again for a huge
chunk of the movie lady this mumbling
warlord to fulfill his overly
complicated plot of terrorizing Gotham
for three pointless months which prompts
only one riot and zero gridlock
seriously where is everybody get ready
for a nearly three hour Batman movie
where Batman only shows up for about 33
minutes and when he does show up he's so
terrible he reveals his secret identity
to complete strangers you started by the
mask
detective people
never conducts background checks on his
maids or his board members he uses
ineffective gadgets stands atop random
buildings that are way too dangerous to
balance on and weigh several hours
painting a bridge in gasoline a story so
large in scale he was partly shot in the
eye bags which become super distracting
when it's constantly changing aspect
ratios and a film so poorly pays it
moves slow for two hours then randomly
zooms through three months of time
without telling the audience foresee
this completely rushed ending that'll
leave you asking questions like why are
the criminals constantly hitting Batman
with their guns instead of shooting him
why would the CIA let mask men onto
their plane without checking who they
were first how did they know about the
existence and the exact location of
Batman's secret armory
especially after Lucius said it was off
the books and why has no one stumbled
upon his huge ass airplane
how did Bane and his henchmen hide
motorcycles inside the stock exchange
how is it possible that Bruce Wayne
completely healed his broken back in
less than three months didn't he need a
doctor
how did Batman get from the hole in the
middle of nowhere into the quarantined
Gotham without any money or equipment
why would they send the entire Gotham
City police force into the sewers all at
the exact same time if Tamil or knew he
was Batman why did she let him wander
off with Lucius why didn't you just kill
him when she had the chance the fact why
didn't she just detonate the bomb right
then and light is Batman and talk to
Catwoman in his Batman voice when she
knows he's Bruce Wayne how come
everybody in Gotham could figure out
that Bruce Wayne was Batman except for
Commissioner Gordon even the character
with Down syndrome played by Joseph
gordon-levitt figured it out why did
Bruce Wayne show up in a French cafe
after being pronounced dead I think that
would have attracted the attention of
the media how did Batman eject and swim
nine miles to survive if he only had
five seconds left on the ball didn't
anyone in Gotham think it was weird that
Batman
an Bruce Wayne both died on the exact
same day Bruce Wayne was Batman story
the cast of Inception Princess Diaries
Kristen Stewart's mouth
my cocaine Bruce Willis and Bane Boo
Boo's The Dark Knight Rises
I'm pretty worried about Man of Steel
now thanks to red letter media be sure
to check them out also check out our
latest cream jockeys episode where we
play some actual fantasy football with
Paul Scheer and storm troopers I'm not
wearing underwear I'm free we are never
ever getting back together giggity
giggity goo all right I'm a Barbie girl
in a Barbie world